Hi. I'm a traditional wife,
and I wanted to discuss today what exactly is a traditional wife? One,
because there's a lot of misconceptions about it,
but there's also people who want to gatekeep
and be the arbiters of what is traditional,
and I just. Dumb.
Traditional wife is somebody who has a traditional marriage.
And what do I mean by traditional marriage?
I mean that their marriage operates within traditional gender roles,
where the husband is the main provider,
he is the main breadwinner,
and he oversees the household,
and the wife is the homemaker.
The help me that comes under her husband's authority in leadership
and submit to him when they disagree.
The reasoning why you would be traditional
can be different across the board.
I'm traditional because I believe in scripture,
and I believe in biblical values.
Other people may have traditional marriages
where they don't believe in god,
they don't believe in the Bible, etc,
but have, quote, unquote,
traditional marriages. It does not look the same across the board.
You don't have to make things from scratch to be a traditional wife.
You don't have to make everybody's clothes,
you don't have to guard them,
you don't have to homestead, okay?
It's not. It's not a monolith.
You are submitting to your husband.
That does not mean you were dumbing yourself down.
And you don't have your own opinions,
and you don't have your own values,
and you just do whatever your husband says.
I Know, people portray that as being traditional,
but god gave you a brain. God gave you a brain.
Use it. While I love baking,
I love being in my kitchen.
I love the aprons, I love the dresses.
I love the general aesthetic of being a traditional wife.
That's not everyone's picture.
The very broad term that people like to put into boxes,
and it's not a boxed thing.